let's hear from some of our viewers
today now we're going to take some calls
via discord you can find the discord at
davidpakman.com
discord now with i don't even know how
many people are subscribed twelve
thousand
thirteen thousand something like that
let's start today with josh
from toledo josh from toledo
you are on the air what's going on
hey man uh not much is going on just you
know finishing up
semesters at college uh
so i just wanted to pick your brain a
little bit
uh if you're okay with it you know i am
okay with it however
pick your brain that's like one of the
red flags at a dinner party if someone
ever says i want to pick your brain i
try to head for the hills because i'm
about to get into a horrible
conversation i'm going to assume that
because it's discord it's not going
south
no no not at all okay um
i just wanted to to get your opinion
a little bit on the problem of
misinformation
in the media and how to combat it yes
that's that's the whole that's the whole
question there was not a specific thing
uh hello yeah sorry i'm i'm trying to be
general here um i i apologize
we'll listen if you want to move on and
i've talked about
the source of a lot of this is we have
people
who reach adulthood and they fall for
this stuff
earlier this week tucker carlson did a
segment
where he simply said i mean this is just
it's so dumb but a lot of people fell
for it
tucker said um why do we need any
coveted precautions
if the vaccines work maybe the fact that
we still have coveted precautions is a
sign
that the vaccines don't work and
people are not maybe it's that they're
not confident enough to think for
themselves
maybe it's that they don't know how to
parse and interpret
and analyze such a media message but
it's like the answer is
not enough people are vaccinated yet
it's really really simple and the only
way to really
almost like inoculate people from that
is you need to be teaching critical
thinking and media literacy much earlier
we're not doing it
it's not getting through people are
getting you know terrible messages about
how to think about things
from uh people they grow up around and
schools that are not working so well
and people in their family and facebook
and whatever else the case may be so
it's not
you know we there are things we can do
to try to fix
media but the real solution would be to
fix
the viewing public so they don't fall
for this garbage
well i completely agree with you on that
but do you think that there is that
there is some advantage in treating
the current media problem like trying to
break a cult
yes no no you you have to think it is
cult-like and we've talked
i have interviews where we talk to cult
experts and they talk about how
there is a cult-like element to what's
going on it should be treated that way
it's an accurate analogy
okay uh also i apologize if i'm bringing
up topics that you have already
covered a lot no problem
yeah the i've been studying
this whole thing personally for
about a year now for one of my degrees
um and
listen yeah i i love it i'm gonna let
you go just because i have so many
people waiting i appreciate the one
question let's look at a second question
maybe
maybe next time uh just because there
are a lot of people waiting to get on
let's go next to horus
from denver horus from denver you are on
the air
hi david how you doing what's up
you tell me so i had a question um yeah
from something i saw on the bonus show
on thursday which i caught later
so i guess that's why i'm calling about
it now
um it was about that uh new utah they've
got
where it's like uh men pay fifty percent
of the pregnancy costs
yes and i wasn't totally sure what you
thought
about that rule that's the only thing i
couldn't glean from it
and then you know what your view of the
child support laws in general yeah so
um with the story is one uh that
that's being mentioned here that we
talked about on the bonus show earlier
this week where utah is moving forward
with a law
where the biological father in a
pregnancy
is responsible for 50 of the cost of the
pregnancy
and birth regardless of sort of like
relationship status or involvement with
the biological
mother and as i said on the bonus show
um i i like the idea
that responsibility should be shared
even though one of the two people who
are biologically the parents
are responsible for the actual birthing
and caring to term of the child the
concerns
include things like well uh if you have
a situation
of either you know domestic violence or
uh a child conceived through rape and
then you are
in theory sort of like tying a guy who
may not be a good guy who the mother may
not want involved
to the child and and what does that do
but can we just deal with that
by keeping the financial responsibility
separate from something that goes beyond
that i mean i think that's the
complexity
i got that i got that i was just
curious what you make of the
i guess there's the argument out there
like should men have the obligation at
all to
be stuck financially too a child at all
and
that was the part i've always been
curious about well what do you think
should they
um i would
i kind of like what they do in sweden
which is they say you can opt out of
fatherhood now they have a robust social
safety net that allows for
you know enables that much better but
there's still the principle
there is still the principle yeah we do
not have that system here in the united
states
right you know that would enable it but
then there's separate from that as the
principle i happen to be of the
persuasion that
it doesn't make a whole lot of sense to
obligate him financially to
do that and uh yeah does the mother have
that same choice could a mother who's
pregnant say
i also don't want to have any financial
responsibility
she has the ability to abort she has all
kinds of options there
comparatively you have a lot fewer
options as a man and
it's kind of you still have to be
responsible though in
seeking out 1k yeah we we seem to be on
a delay and
yeah okay i'm going to let you go for
now the connection is aggressively bad
um i think there's a lot of issues there
uh wrapped up in that not not all of
which we are uh
necessarily able to get to right now
let's go to
ricky from charlotte ricky from
charlotte you are on the air
hey david can you hear me all right i
can hear you fine
cool so i wanted to ask real quick about
florida
i think it's been a pretty big disaster
for the democrats
past few election cycles and
uh the way that i see it it looks like
desantis is gonna cruise to
his re-election um just the way things
stand right now
but i did see that the agriculture
commissioner of florida she's like the
only statewide elected democrat
overall she's a pretty generic um
inviting type democrat but she is pretty
big on pro legalizing marijuana
and they're also trying to get a ballot
initiative for legalizing it in 2022.
do you think if she if they tried to run
a campaign
where uh she is uh saying you know
vote for me and vote for legalizing weed
it pulls pretty well like over 60
which is what they need yeah and you
know if you elect me
uh we're gonna implement it quickly
without restrictions the samples would
ruin it and all that do you think that
could
help them uh get him out of office i
think it could i mean
florida is such a strange place in terms
of his its election dynamics and then it
also has
um you know the the the additional kind
of like x factor
of the cuban population of course most
voters uh from central and south america
vote mostly for democrats cubans are the
the primary exception to that you also
have a lot of
um folks who are you know we could say
they colloquially live in florida but
they may not vote in florida because
they only spend part of the year there
so sometimes even like the people you
see in florida and talk to aren't
necessarily florida
voters you also have the opposite people
who you would think are voting elsewhere
but are actually voting in florida
i i i think that there's a real
opportunity because we do see that
sometimes you see a dynamic in certain
states
where even though they're still voting
for a lot of republicans
on issues and on ballot initiatives and
on local races you start seeing them
move to the left
and it can be like a leading indicator
as to what is eventually going to happen
so i like the idea that you're
suggesting i think trying to
um uh help the left by by
attaching a candidate potentially to a
ballot initiative
or issue based campaign is a really
great idea but i don't pretend to know
enough about the wackiness of florida
to be able to say for sure whether it
would be effect it would be successful
yeah i i hear what you're saying and you
know i
i just think that desantis especially
he's a big political threat to the
democrats i i feel
like he's uh a really good chance at
being the
nominee in 24 without trump so i think
that
if he lost his re-election that would be
a big um
you know that that would be a big blow
to um
his nomination chances but
you know i i i don't i think you're
probably thinking of this idea that
you're you're not gonna do well if the
last thing you did was lose a race but
look at joe biden joe biden
you know lost the primary in 2016
and then he won the primary and became
president you could say 2020 was an
outlier
but it's not that obvious to me that
desantis
he wasn't in the primary i thought he
didn't run
biden was not oh wait hold on my no
biden ran no biden did run
wait did biden not run in 2016 now i
don't even remember
no because it's because uh uh because
beau
died and he uh because bo
died like not long before the election
he said he like just wasn't emotionally
ready he was thinking about oh yeah
that's right what am i even talking
about
yeah it's all good hey listen you know
what you may be you may be completely
right on desantis no i mean i think i
might the principle i think it's not
totally clear to me that a desantis loss
is the end for him for 2024. i just
think what's going the republican
anything could happen in the republican
party once trump won a republican
primary
it's sort of like all bets are off
anything could happen and we already saw
nikki haley say this week that if trump
runs she won't and she will support
trump
i think for the most part um people are
going to be deferring to trump in 2024
yeah well the yeah i'm just the santas
just worries me because
i feel like he'd be a more effective
trump he's like if trump's fashionism
went to law school
right no i completely agree he has all
the same bad instincts and a morality of
trump but he's
more competent and more polished and
more polished yeah exactly
all right ricky thank you for the call i
appreciate it yep
all right there it is